now turning to our next guest you're
going to love this the critically
acclaimed actress julia lewis she's
known for playing edgy and offbeat
characters in her latest project she's
starring in a psychological thriller
called yellow jackets it's about a high
school soccer team that is involved in a
plane crash 25 years ago on their way to
a game the girls are left stranded in
the wilderness the show follows their
struggle to stay alive and bounces back
and forth between the crash and present
day where lewis's character natalie is
still dealing with the
trauma after they rescued us
i
i lost my purpose
and
thanks to my time here
i finally know how to get it back
julia lewis joins us right now you can
play creepy very well juliette i finally
gotta get it back
now now you wanted me to just be like
deadpan you know and you captured it
this this series is dark and it it
tackles themes about survival
and also mental health yeah um what drew
you to this role
well it was one of the best scripts i'd
read in the past 10 years which is
really saying something because i read a
lot of them
and the characters just left off the
page and the stories were so it was just
so original
um
yeah it's really complicated you
mentioned mental health they're doing it
wrong like each character is
surviving
or denying their history in a very um
complicated human behavior way which is
what i love about acting yeah because
they called it a cross between mean
girls and lord of the flies do you think
that's a pretty good description and you
have a double cast because for your each
character there's a younger actress or
actor playing you do you think that's a
good comparison though lord of the flies
and mean girls i think so you know you
need uh or to quote my co-star tawny
cypress she calls it um oh wait 50
shades of cray
that's her question that's good
that's good but uh yeah it's it's funny
too you the first three episodes you're
gonna get hooked is super suspenseful
and then once christina ricci's
character and myself go on a road trip
it's uh i nicknamed us betty and um wait
was it bonnie joan oh no betty and joan
sorry after betty davis and joan
crawford cause me and christina
been in the business so long and we
didn't know how uh similar we worked it
was really cute what was it like having
younger actors and play each of you i
thought that that was also an
interesting dynamic because as nate
mentioned it goes current day to to back
in time oh yeah so it's funny because
when you're i've done been in this
business a long time so i love when
there's a first yeah and i've never had
a so a younger person play my
self and help tell the story of my
character and so my younger self was um
sophie thatcher and she has a deep voice
too which is did you guys work together
we did we just
the casting was so good because
there's just a vibe between each
character and it's perfectly matched but
sophie and i like share different
musical references
we mentioned people like nina haagen i
don't know
i i love if anybody in your audience
knows of the music in the nina hogan
this is very good music yes music is
really speaking of music though you're a
singer you're a musician
do the two art forms reinforce or
benefit one another
being an actress and being a musician
that's exactly right um
well so when i was working in movies
early on i would always use music to get
right into a scene so like i could tell
you
every character like natural burn
killers i was listening to jimi hendrix
voodoo child slight return on repeat for
a month
um i know every bend in his guitar
uh and then um cape fear i was listening
to all this like like the sherelles and
like
bubblegum like um love music because she
was
a teenager
so i just feel that music is a shortcut
to the emotions are you bringing your
musical career back because you left
acting to pursue music and now are you
coming back with music yes
tell us as you know we all just went
through a collective yeah very difficult
time right
so i am like feverish hungry to get into
everything all my creative loves
and um i'm getting the band back
together okay yeah
um it's juliette in the list breaking
news yeah yeah yeah juliette and the
delix
but we just had our little zoom
on you know talking about our demos
that we're gonna you know find what
songs we're gonna
pursue are you excited about that juliet
because really we were all took a big
time out oh yeah you're excited about
exploring the music side of you again i
love it i'm just i'm just really into
connecting with people and doing what we
can because we were told what we can't
do right and there's a whole bunch of
can right now and so i just want to step
into that that yes zone that's a
beautiful way to put it i know i like
that too thank you you can do it all and
we're also looking forward to mayday
your action film that you uh have coming
out yeah streaming right now no doubt no
doubt julia louis thank you so much
yellowjacket premieres on sunday
november 14th on show time a division of
viacom cbs what happens in the woods
that's a big question yes indeed what
happened who's talking